dans ses cartons des pâtes des biscuits
ou des boissons tous ont un point commun
ils sont fabriqués en eure et loir où
zones limitrophes
en tout plus de 500 produits secs et
frais sont référencés ici dans cette
nouvelle plateforme baptisée sur le
champ une plateforme créée en juin
dernier pour mettre en relation
producteurs d'un côté et épiceries et
restaurateurs euréliens de l'autre tous
tentent de répondre à une demande
croissante de produits locaux de la part
des consommateurs et du côté des
professionnels qui travaillent sur les
produits locaux on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait une grosse demande et qui
enfin certains avaient des difficultés
aussi à d
s'approvisionner en produits locaux donc
soit il s'agissait d'adapter chacun des
producteurs individuellement pour ce
faire et pas tous au même moment
désormais distributeurs et restaurateurs
peuvent contacter cette plateforme qui
répercute les commandes auprès de
producteurs locaux comme benoît lemaire
cet arboriculteur est en pleine récolte
de pommes s'il en est cool la moitié en
vente directe il s'est tout de suite
inscrit sur cette plateforme qui à terme
va récupérer les denrées de plusieurs
producteurs et les livrer en une fois si
vous avez plus cher de transport que de
produits ça devient pas raisonnable au
niveau du consommateur le prix est trop
élevé après donc là on va avoir un
système qui va nous permettre de livrer
des quantités plus petite un peu plus
loin
bref mais qui reste globalement sur le
département benoît le maire espère ainsi
vendre ses pommes dans les jardineries
mais aussi en restauration collective
comme dans les cantines scolaires de
l'eure et loir